it seems like Dwayne has like the next
year or to figure it out what's actually
coming up for you guys that you're super
excited about yeah we're we're very
fortunate we have a great slate coming
up and so the next the first thing we
have coming up after we do a little bit
of press as Jumanji is coming out this
December and then in January we get into
red notice red notice which is
unbelievably exciting we got Ryan
Reynolds the cow Godot bring in rawson
thurber back a big comedy action heist
thriller that is globe-trotting
so we're really thrilled with that we
just set that up at Netflix and then
sometime later that year the way it's
looking is we have a little something
called Black Adam that is coming up
that's where I was gonna ask you about
did the I'm all of us have been waiting
for this movie you and me both right so
is it for sure that it's going next year
with the success of Shazam it is uh well
definitely the success of Shazam was
awesome to us and it was important for
us to launch that get that into the
world and just begin crafting this
universe you know it's a big thing for
us to start to create this universe this
DC section of the universe that we're
working on with characters we have
planned to bring into it headline by
Shazam black Adam but yeah the idea is
is if everything falls in line right now
joma joma Clutts era he just closed this
deal which we're very excited about and
you know the plan is to be filming that
end of next year